presented by the boys taking the fight
to superheroes on Amazon Prime video on
July 26th in a world where a bankrupt
comic book company sold the film rights
to its best characters for peanuts
because they thought movies would be a
good way to put some more comics a young
executive will do what he can with the
rejects that no one wanted and do so
well they get bought out by Disney
before it was cool the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
except for endgame welcome to the MCU a
TV series made of movies about comic
books where magic is actually science
your ancestors called it magic and you
call it science but not by magic by
technology magic science but science is
basically magic organization I didn't
physically check the crates and meet
your typical MCU protagonist a loner
with no pets no biological siblings and
whose only friends are their co-workers
Oh whose personality can range from my
heartache whipster balance is closed
today
to stern duty-bound military type you
get hurt or them back get killed walk it
off and on a long enough timeline
everyone becomes equip stir that's
please you've been to space follow along
on their hero's journeys where after a
motivating Uncle Ben situation they'll
get a transformational hairstyle cut
some cards and find the strength to
boldly say their superhero name out loud
Captain America
confor son of Odin man I'm Nick Fury
I'm Peter bodily dr. strange Oh using a
made-up names um
I'm spider-man then star-lord who but
people say a hero is only as good as
their villain and thank god that's not
true or the MCU would be hot garbage
thrill as they spare 10 minutes to
establish a bad guy who's just like the
hero but evil or a faceless horde can't
feel bad if it doesn't have a face or
actually a pretty awesome character and
they're dead but everyone knows the real
villain of the MCU is dads he was cold
he was calculating he never told me he
loved me and never even told me he liked
me favored to turn your backs on the
rest of the world I will hunt my father
like a dog and I will tear him apart
slowly piece by piece until he knows
some semblance of the profound and
unceasing pain I know every single
tremble before the girth of a
meticulously planned story told across
23 separate movies all about Thanos
killing have the universe well first he
has to get an Infinity Gauntlet no not
that God yeah yeah that one and then
gathered the Infinity stones will send
proxies to get them and it gives one
away but eventually he'll get the stones
some art stones while the other etics
often appear as stones the ether is
fluid but then he'll kill half the
universe which also doesn't make much
sense oh also the timeline doesn't work
out maybe this wasn't so planned out
after all but the film's do sort nicely
into three distinct phases the
conventional pop songs phase the
boundary-pushing experimental phase then
and if rock ducks have taught me
anything
phase four will have the MCU puking in
the gutter wondering where it all went
wrong sure
from the farthest reaches of biking
space to alternate dimensions to the
wonders of Earth oops that one Zootopia
and Marvel and how everything still kind
of looks and feels the same as visionary
indie filmmakers are funneled into the
Marvel style of overlit digital video
where everything is CGI every story is
full of sexless romance that never takes
off bloodless violence that never leaves
more than a couple of forehead scrapes
all that for a drop of blood lifeless
soundtracks with more dad rock than you
can shake a pair of middle-aged
screenwriters at feel so good Chuck
Mangione in 1977 Marvin Gaye 1972
Trouble Man soundtrack or toothless
comedy that's just saying pop culture
things so this orb has a real shiny blue
suitcase Ark of the Covenant Maltese
Falcon is sort of five I'd loved you in
A Christmas Story I'm shooting Knight
Rider or touring with his band in
Germany no hard feelings Point Break you
got a mean swing will build my new Lego
Death Star
what try me Beyonce that man is playing
Galaga every Steve is really old movie
aliens we're getting no help from Flash
Gordon I can first move exactly like
Footloose it's good work grimace like a
personal flying monkeys I understood
that reference Blue Lagoon Gandalf and
Harry Potter oops that's pixels so
settle in for an interconnected movie
verse that had a 1 in 14 million 605
shot of working but those odds didn't
stop every other studio for awkwardly
mashing their eye piece together like a
junior high dance floor leaving marble
as the only one standing in a dying
industry to do this other but launching
a whole new industry of Marvel movie
news theory and analysis channels that
just complain about Marvel movies and
even comedy web series that would have
died a long time ago if Marvel movies
weren't so popular so one way or another
in the end
everyone's getting paid by Disney you
shills
starring
science geniuses it could achieve heavy
ion fusion at any reactor on the planet
quantum phases where an object moves
through different states of matter
einstein-rosen bridge is a theoretical
connection between two different points
of space the wormhole via quantum system
would revert back to separate states of
matter
why didn't you just reprogram the
synapses to work connectively when did
you become an expert in thermonuclear
astrophysics last night jumping out of
airplanes
[Music]
people of color leg scissors
brains
Howdy's unless you're ant-man then you
get a Hyundai and you like it dual
wielding
dick-measuring I'm having the gun you
are not the big gun Tony
don't be jealous good raging fire so I
like smoldering my record 21 feet
not bad you 65 huge 65 you get an Iron
Man suit and you get an Iron Man suit
and you get an Iron Man suit weird non
Stanley cameos different electric jet
[Applause]
boaty hit combos
[Music]
are you sure you know how to fly this
thing you know how to fly this thing uh
we'll see I thought you said he knew how
to fly this thing I said how hard could
it be here take the wheel no I don't
know how to fly one of these you're a
scientist you running a PhD and never
forget that for all of Guardians 1
they're sitting in star-lords jizz find
a black light this is look like a
Jackson Pollock painting uh-huh gross
dude the neverending story oh man we
forgot to say anything about the ABC
shows Netflix series 1 shots and
spin-offs yeah so did Kevin Feige this
episode was brought to you by the boys a
new series on Amazon Prime video
premiering on July 26th is the first
episode of our new series fandom
uncovered all about Twilight fans yes do
we have the healthiest history with
Twilight not so much but should you
check out the official launch of our new
series heck yes you should